tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel le
boeing de la lufthansa
le commandant de bord a battu un nouveau
délai fixé à 1h03 tf1 en couleurs
raymond barre à lyon demandent une
accélération du programme de coloration
concorde à new york
premier vol commercial le 22 novembre
prochain janus quatre premières plongées
réussi pour la première fois au monde
six hommes en eau libre à moins 460 m la
course autour du monde
les premières images rapportées par le
concurrent bernard de guy notre envoyé
spécial bonsoir la situation créée par
le détournement d'avion de la lufthansa
est ressentie avec une telle gravité à
travers le monde que je viens de
l'apprendre à l'instant et pour la
première fois le pape paul 6 offert sa
vie pour le salut des otages du boeing
jusqu'où va aller la résistance du
gouvernement allemand devant l'odieux
l'insupportable chantage à la vie
exercée par une poignée de terroristes
qui détiennent toujours à mogadiscio en
somalie
les passagers et l'équipage du boeing de
la lufthansa jusqu'à maintenant le
gouvernement allemand avait réussi à ne
pas céder sans mettre en danger la vie
des otages mais les données du drame ont
beaucoup changé depuis qu'il est devenu
tragédie avec l'assassinât du pilote de
l'avion jeter ce matin sur la piste de
mogadiscio
pourtant le gouvernement de bonn refuse
de répondre quand on lui pose la
question allez-vous maintenant libéré
les 11 membres de la bande à baader
objet du chantage il répond simplement
qu'une liaison téléphonique permanente a
été établi avec mogadiscio la capitale
de la somalie
ce qui signifie qu'à partir de francfort
où peut parler avec les pirates
par l'intermédiaire de la tour de
contrôle ces derniers ont fait savoir
qu'ils repoussaient leur ultimatum à 0
heures 30 gmt une heure et demie heure
française le gouvernement de somalie
voudrait que cet avion s'en aille
les terroristes n'ont plus guère de
territoire de refuge en perspective
et surtout il n'y a plus que le copilote
puisque le commandant de bord a été tué
éric gilbert
oui le corps du commandant schuman a été
éjecté de l'appareil ce matin à 7h30 sur
la piste de mogadiscio par un toboggan
de secours
mais ce n'est qu'en début d'après midi
l'identité de la victime a été connue
les autorités ayant tardé à la confirmer
pour leur part les pirates n'ont pas
tenté de justifier ce meurtre ou tout au
moins les explications qu'ils ont pu
fournir n'ont pas été retransmise mais
pour autant qu'on le sache
le pilote que l'on va voir maintenant au
cours d'une opération de ravitaillement
sur l'aéroport de dubaï il a 48 heures
le pilote et l'homme en chemise blanche
qui surveillait actuellement par un
terroriste et bien ce pilote n'a pas été
supprimée pour faire fléchir les
autorités il aurait été dur est abattu
dès la nuit dernière à aden
sans doute jürgen schumann at il payé de
sa vie une attitude extrêmement
courageuse on sait en effet qu'en
utilisant des phrases codet il avait
réussi au cours de l'escale de dubaï à
faire passer un certain nombre
d'informations sur le commando il avait
révélé en particulier que les
terroristes étaient amenés armés de
pistolets 9 mm et disposer de pains de
plastique
d'après l agence de presse ouest
allemande jürgen schumann aurait été
exécuté devant tous les passages
depuis rien n'a bougé autour du boeing
isolé sur la piste de l'aéroport
somaliens par un cordon d'hommes en
armes
seul réconfort pour les otages qui en
sont à leur sixième jour la nuit est
maintenant tombée et la température va
baisser de quelques degrés latitude du
commando dirigé par le mystérieux valter
mohamed est complexe
d'un côté une extrême dureté les pirates
refusent tout ce qui pourrait rendre la
détention des otages moins pénible au
fil des étapes qu'ils n'ont libéré
personnes alors qu'il y à bord des
personnes âgées à la santé fragile des
femmes et des enfants
d'un autre côté ces pirates semblent
pris de court il fixe de nouveaux délais
d'une façon assez incohérent tantôt il
rajoute une demi-heure tantôt plusieurs
heures le dernier ultimatum expirera à
1h30 cette nuit
il faut dire aussi qu'il pensait avoir
moins de difficulté à trouver un asile
et puis c'est également un élément
important il ya maintenant une sorte
d'écran entre eux et le monde extérieur
le gouvernement d'allemagne de l'ouest a
obtenu que le black out soit respectée
il ne donne aucune précision sur les
contacts entre l'avion et les autorités
contactons le par le truchement de la
tour de contrôle de francfort et à bonn
on continue de penser que cette taxe
si tu es la seule possible nous allons
retrouver maintenant notre envoyé
spécial en allemagne fédérale
bernard wolker pour un dernier point n'a
pas entamé la détermination du
gouvernement allemand de ne pas céder au
chantage des terroristes
le porte-parole du gouvernement fédéral
a été pour la première fois très clair
cet après midi en dix ans les
terroristes doivent abandonner cette
attitude de fermeté et compris par
l'opinion
elle a en revanche choqué les parents
des otages dont certains se sont rendu
cet après-midi à la chancellerie pour
demander à leurs gouvernements de tout
faire pour sauver la vie des passagers
de l'avion de la luz ans allemand est en
contact permanent avec son noviciat la
mogadiscio avec les pirates de l'air la
série de parties de poker continue oui
nous retrouverons bernard volker un fan
journal pour un nouveau point sur cette
affaire
les dirigeants européens se sentent
parfaitement concernés par ce qui se
passe en allemagne dans une conversation
téléphonique monsieur giscard d'estaing
a assuré le chancelier schmitt que la
france demeurait aux côtés du
gouvernement fédéral dans cette épreuve
le gouvernement britannique a parlé d'
appui total à bonn
ce qui est en jeu surtout c'est
l'engrenage de la violence qui peut
aller jusqu'à entamer les principes même
le fonctionnement de la démocratie
libérale
on observe le gouvernement de bonn on
approuve ces décisions on lui donne son
appui et plus généralement on s'inquiète
de ce qu'une telle situation puisse
déboucher sur des procédures et des lois
d'exception tel a été le sens des propos
de raymond barre tout à l'heure à llo
nous traversons dans tous les pays une
période difficile car c'est la
démocratie qui est menacée la démocratie
c'est la tolérance c'est le respect des
opinions est ce le respect des hommes
voilà pourquoi je crois que lorsqu'il
s'agit de défendre la démocratie il faut
la plus grande fermeté on se repent
toujours de certaine complaisance ou de
certaines faiblesses le passé l'a montré
si tous nos pays ne parviennent pas à
surmonter ce que le chancelier l'ancien
chancelier brandt a appelé une crise de
civilisation en montrant que la
démocratie et ses principes se défendent
alors je pense que la vie deviendra de
plus en plus difficile pour les citoyens
voilà et je vous rappelle l'information
que je vous donnais au début de ce
journal qui est tout à fait étonnant
tout à fait exceptionnel le pape paul 6
offert sa vie pour sauver les otages
pour le salut des otages et
renseignements pris par un confrère qui
vient de téléphoner à rome cela signifie
bien que le peuple cif s'offre lui même
à la place des otages
le premier ministre a fait la
déclaration que vous avez entendu il ya
quelques minutes à l'occasion de sa
visite officielle à lyon qui a commencé
par l'inauguration de l'émetteur
couleurs de tf1 en compagnie de jean
autun le président de télédiffusion de
france et de jean cazeneuve le président
de tf1 les téléspectateurs lyonnais qui
ont un récepteur appropriés peuvent donc
nous voir ce soir pour la première fois
en couleurs
le premier ministre a annoncé d'ailleurs
qu'à la fin de l'année les émetteurs de
marseille et aix ayant été créée près de
la moitié de la population française
pourra recevoir les trois chaînes en
couleur et puis il a demandé qu'on
accélère le reste du programme d'un an
et demi à peu près si bien qu'en juin 82
il devrait être achevé
cela a amené raymond barre à une
réflexion beaucoup plus large sur la
télévision son monopole technique at il
dit n'est pas un monopole des idées
personne ne peut sérieusement prétendre
que dans ce pays la télévision soit le
monopole de quiconque
j'entends même parfois at il ajouté
quelques murmures à l'encontre de la
place accordée sur les antennes à ceux
qui un jour au pouvoir n'aurait de cesse
d'y faire régner le monopole d'une
idéologie le pluralisme des opinions est
la règle il sera respecté fin de
citation cela engage et bien le propos
politique
premier ministre qui ne l'oublions pas a
confirmé sa candidature aux législatives
dans la 4e circonscription de lyon et
qui a déclaré je conduirai la campagne
comme chef du gouvernement
patrice duhamel à lyon raymond barre il
l'a dit tout à l'heure n'aime pas
mélanger les gens c'est donc beaucoup
plus le premier ministre et chef
politique de la majorité que le candidat
aux élections législatives ici dans la
4e circonscription du rhône qui est
apparue premier ministre responsable du
redressement économique
raymond barre a annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures techniques pour aider
les petites et moyennes entreprises et
en particulier pour faciliter leur accès
aux marchés financiers mais surtout
c'est le chef politique de la majorité
qui est apparu on le sait pour le
premier ministre le paysage politique a
beaucoup changé depuis la cassure entre
les socialistes et les communistes à
partir de là un certain nombre de
perspectives nouvelles doivent être
envisagées à partir de là on peut penser
que beaucoup d'idées reçues doivent
tomber
c'est donc à partir de cette analyse que
le premier ministre a édifié ce que l'on
peut penser comme étant un plan barre
politique pour les élections
législatives un plan barre en trois
thèmes
premièrement il ne faut pas avoir de
complexes vis-à-vis de ce qui a été fait
au cours des dernières années
deuxièmement la coupure entre la gauche
et la droite est artificielle
troisièmement le progrès social c'est la
majorité qui l'a engagé et c'est la
majorité qui doit le poursuivre à la
donc une synthèse maintenant de ce que
raymond barre nous a annoncé en
exclusivité dans notre édition de 13
heures je voudrais leur dire trois
choses la première c'est qu'il n'y a
aucune raison que ceux qui ont assumé
depuis 20 ans et au cours de ces
dernières années les responsabilités
face un complexe quelconque ou et
mauvaise conscience comme l'opposition
tend à vouloir la leur donner deuxième
thème je crois important nous devons
refuser systématiquement l'opposition
artificielle qui est faite entre la
droite et la gauche
cela n'a pas de sens il y a en france un
courant qui est celui de la tradition et
de l'ordre et il y à un courant qui est
celui du progrès et du changement
un courant n'est pas d'un côté et le
second courant d'un autre côté ce que
nous voulons ce n'est pas du tout battre
la gauche
ce que nous voulons c'est battre
l'opposition et nous voulons battre
l'opposition parce que l'opposition
défend un programme commun qui est plein
de dangers pour les français qui risque
de compromettre leur avenir
aussi bien sur le plan de l'économie que
sur le plan des libertés et la troisième
chose que je crois très importante c'est
d'expliquer aux électeurs aux françaises
et aux français qu'il n'y a pas une
politique conservatrice de classe qui
est menée par le gouvernement et qui a
été soutenu par la majorité et par
ailleurs une politique de progrès social
qui résoudrait tous les problèmes
la vraie politique de progrès social
c'est nous qui la mène le patronat la
grande offensive de relations publiques
destinée à montrer que les chefs
d'entreprise sont les champions du
dynamisme social s'achèvera demain sur
une synthèse de françois ceyrac les
patrons sont particulièrement satisfaits
de leur forum public du week-end où ils
ont accueilli raymond barre jacques
chirac et surtout des milliers de
visiteurs qui ont pu discuter
directement avec les plus grands chefs
d'autres dans tous les plus grands chefs
d'entreprise cela prouve que nous sommes
bien considérés comme les premiers
interlocuteurs valables pour ce qui
concerne la vie économique du pays
déclare et on a l'occasion de ces
assises nationales
aujourd'hui on a assisté à une série de
travaux sur les thèmes l'homme et
l'entreprise l'entreprise et la cité qui
définissent bien la nouvelle stratégie
du patronat il y à l'évidence un souci
de contre attaque dénoncée comme
électoraliste par les critiques pour
prouver que les chefs de la libre
entreprise sont les véritables garants
du progrès social dans toutes ses
dimensions
emmanuel de la taille
le patronat à bras ouverts le plus
important dans cette énorme opération
c'est la volonté des patrons de
démontrer eux-mêmes qu'ils sont capables
d'organiser les changements souhaités au
lieu de subir passivement les attaques
et les projets imposer une petite
révolution chez des hommes qui n'aiment
pas tellement s'afficher sur les
tréteaux ce qui les a projetés dans la
mêlée la crise la conscience
d'aspirations nouvelles
le programme commun qu'ils connaissent
aussi bien que des militants communistes
et la conviction qu'ils doivent aller de
l'avant sur tous les axes du progrès
social
finalement trois thèmes l'autodéfense
malgré la crise on a continué à
améliorer les conditions de vie et de
travail fini en principe lusine caserne
d'autant que la crise en limitant les
salaires oblige à d'autres progrès
secundo la contre attaque les
expérimentations réussies au banc
d'essai doivent être élargies à
l'ensemble des entreprises exemple
horaires à la carte usine à la campagne
décentralisation des décisions et cetera
après la percée le quadrillage sociale
enfin la mobilisation générale pour un
bond en avant le patronat reprend les
thèmes politiques comme liberté
responsabilité initiative en visant les
quarts les ouvriers et surtout les
jeunes notamment sur un point capital
on s'efforce de persuader des dirigeants
encore réticents qu'un commandement -
autoritariste loin de relâcher la
discipline est une condition absolue
pour intégrer les jeunes aux entreprises
pour les adversaires du patronat tout
ceci n'est qu'une gigantesque opération
de récupération entre la gauche et le
fait est que plus le patronat se défend
de faire de la politique plus il en fait
au sens large
en sortant de son ancien sanctuaire
concorde à new york
et bien maintenant ça y est c'est pour
dans les jours qui viennent les premiers
vols commerciaux new york paris pour air
france et londres paris pour la british
airways sont affichées pour le 22
novembre
les premiers vols de reconnaissance
peuvent commencer et dès mercredi
une équipe de tf1 est prêt à partir pour
la première liaison concorde a gagné une
bataille vital lorsque ce matin la cour
suprême des etats-unis faisait paraître
un communiqué laconique la demande de
suspension présentée au juge marshall
est référée par lui à la cour est refusé
ça met fin à un an et demi de procédure
et d'atermoiements puisque c'est le 4
février 1976
que le ministre américain des transports
avait donné son accord pour une période
d'essai de 16 mois de concorde à
washington et à new york que c'est
seulement aujourd'hui que cet accord
peut entrer dans les faits l'équité
l'emportent notre père et notre
persévérance aussi a déclaré tout à
l'heure marcel cavaillé le caillavet
pardon le oui oui cavaillé le secrétaire
d'état aux transports
mais l'autorité portuaire de new york
n'a pas désarmé elle continuera sans
doute la bataille sur les nouvelles
normes de bruit qui exclurait le
supersonique quoi qu'il en soit la
décision d'aujourd'hui est de première
importance comme l'ont confirmé pierre
giraud des pdg d'air france et gilbert
pérol le directeur général maintenant
que nous avons la décision de la de la
cour suprême les vols d'essai de
reconnaissance vont commencer dès cette
semaine
monsieur pérol après les vols de
reconnaissance vols commerciaux
l'ouverture finalement de ligne paris
new york pour caen et bien aux alentours
du 22 novembre avec comme horaire un
horaire de jour départ de paris 11
heures arrivée à new york à 8h30 et dans
l'autre sens départ de new york à 10h30
arrivée à paris à 20 heures le soir un
tarif
tarifs 20 % de plus que le tarif
première classe quelque chose que vous
4000 francs et quelques sur le trajet
paris new york
monsieur le président dernière question
est ce que le cas échéant une nouvelle
réglementation du bruit donné par le
poignard pourrait remettre en cause
finalement cette autorisation sur new
york
mais nous ne voyons pas comment une
telle
réglementation pourrait remettre en
cause l'arrivée de new york l'arrivée à
concorde encore un new york
nous ne voyons pas parce qu' une telle
une telle réglementation devrait être
discriminatoire il est bien certain que
le concorde ne fait pas plus de bruit à
new york ne fera pas plus de bruit
qu'une bonne partie des appareils
subsonic qui atterrissent actuellement
sur cet aéroport
ils vendent donc interdire non seulement
concorde mais tous ces appareils
donc tous pensons qu'il n'y a pas de
réglementation qui permettent d'éliminer
le corps de new york avec l'opération
janus 4 des plongeurs bien entraînés
vont s'apprête à réaliser un fantastique
exploit au large du port de bord mule
bormes les mimosas en méditerranée la
première plongée devait avoir lieu
aujourd'hui et bien été reportée à
demain matin
six hommes en tout cas vont tenter de
battre le record du monde de plongée
sous la mer par moins 460 mètres de
profondeur ils effectueront des plongées
deux par deux jusqu'au 19 octobre
ou même un peu plus tard une tourelle de
plonger les descendra à -400 ou 430
mètres ensuite ils iront en nageant vers
un chantier fictif car ses hommes
doivent travailler à cette profondeur
c'est le but de l'opération
ils auront à raccorder des tuyaux de
pipelines pendant chaque fois deux
heures
oui exploit fantastique tout simplement
parce qu'il ya dix ans on croyait que
l'on ne pouvait pas descendre et à voir
les activités au delà de moins de 70
mètres de profondeur michel chevalet est
sur place pour nous parler de cette
opération janus 4 à laquelle a assisté
ou devait assister le ministre de
l'industrie monsieur monory dans ces
deux caissons six hommes vivent à une
pression de 43 bar 43 fois la pression
atmosphérique c'est celle qui existe par
430 mètres de fond sous la mer car c'est
là que ces six plongeurs doivent
descendre un record du monde
la matière dans leurs questions ils
respirent un mélange d'hélium et
d'oxygène 99% d'hélium pour 1% d'oxygène
c'est le secret de la réussite de cette
opération janus 4 qui plus est pour
éviter des troubles nerveux du à
l'hélium
on assume de temps à autre un tout petit
peu d'azoté c'est une recette maison
du caisson par groupe de deux toujours à
la pression de 43 barre ils vont gagner
cette cloche de plongée qui va jouer le
rôle d'ascenseur entre la surface et le
fond de la mer
nous sommes à bord du pétrel le navire
de forage affrété par elf qui sert de
base logistique à l'opération
au bout du 30 il est suspendu nacelle
sur laquelle se trouve le chantier sous
marins deux tuyaux à souder
autour du pétrel deux autres bâtiments
le triton de la marine nationale et le
suroît du cnec saut le but de
l'opération janus 4 et de voir
l'attitude des hommes à travailler par
460 mètres de fond celle ferrater dans
des caissons mais on l'a encore jamais
fait dans des conditions réelles
le ministre de l'industrie monsieur
monory a voulu se rendre compte de ce
que cela représentait il est descendu à
bord de la soucoupe plongeante scianna
pour inspecter le chantier sous marle un
petit voyage de deux heures au fond de
la mer à l'endroit même où sera battu ce
record du monde de plongée
alors après cette promenade à 500 mètres
de profondeur je trouve c'est formidable
je n'avais aucune appréhension
je connais la qualité des techniciens du
centre d'exploitation des océans je suis
absolument ravi j'ai vu l'installation
des plongeurs j'ai pris la chance de
voir les plongeurs julien de thé
décalage dans l'horreur mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je souhaite que
les français tournent leur regard vers
ce que nous avons de bien en france de
façon responsable
cette avance technologique que nous
avons encore heureusement dans beaucoup
de domaines dont celui là dans la course
autour du monde des voiliers et bien
c'est l'entracte c'est le repos à
kempton 15 bateaux vous en souvenez son
père et de son parti de plymouth le 27
août dernier et lé 15 sont arrivés y
compris 33 export pour lequel on se fait
beaucoup de soucis ces jours ci mais
c'était à tort puisque 33 export est
bien arrivé à cape town
il a tout de même huit jours d'heure de
retard c'est un handicap pour la suite
pour lui nous notre bateau favoris vous
le savez sans doute si vous avez écouté
les récentes émissions en fin de journal
notre bateau favori c'est neptune c'est
neptune et son skipper
bernard de guy qui est notre source qui
perd son capitaine bernard de guy notre
confrère notre envoyé spécial de tf1 sur
cette course autour du monde et berne
argue de guy et là il revient de cape
town
il revient par avion bien sûr juste pour
nous raconter un petit peu cette
première étape
et moi je trouve que vous avez l'air de
revenir un peu d'un stage aux glénan bah
ça a été un peu plus long qu'un stage
oubliant ce que ça a duré 43 jours mais
sinon sa part été beaucoup plus dur pas
beaucoup plus dur commence et on a même
des coups de vent dans une course comme
ça il ya des noms adultes et il n'a
jamais eu plus de 35 devant et en fait
ça a été un rodage parfait pour le
bateau pour le matériel et pour
l'équipage qui a appris à trouver sa
place dans les manoeuvres de pont et
et à l'intérieur de toi si je comprends
bien c'est maintenant que la course
commence pour vous oui je pense qu'on
avait fait un bateau spécialement pour
la crosstour du monde et que c'est
maintenant que ça va se jouer dans
l'océan indien dans le pacifique
alors on est de vous pour cette course
puisque vous avez quand même 92 heures
de retard sur fly reste que c'est
dramatique
non ça représente un jour et demi à
reprendre par étape s'est pas trop c'est
pas trop loin comme handicap quelle
route allez-vous prendre parce que la
première fois se tromper de 92 eur ça
veut dire quand une petite erreur de
route c'est à dire que maintenant ça va
ça va se jouer avec les dépressions et
avec une route la plus courte possible
en descendant dans le sud
ça y est on en joue avec le froid et les
vents forts musique quarantièmes
rugissants
c'est ça oui où les bons vents d'ouest
dans les manuels français vous sentez
plus fort dans cette deuxième partie de
la course
disons que le bateau est beaucoup mieux
d'armer parce qu'on n'a rien cassé dans
la première étape donc normalement
le bateau est parfaitement prêt pour
affronter le gros temps de ces deux
dernières ces deux étapes suivantes et a
priori le bateau va donner tout son
potentiel de vitesse maintenant bernard
de guy bon vous êtes parti unique aux
copains est ce que ce n'est pas
difficile de vivre dans un univers clos
qui est un bateau
pendant si longtemps si ça demande quand
même pas mal d'efforts de la part les
uns et des autres pour supporter les
petits travers qu'on ne voit absolument
pas quand on vit à terre normalement et
qui deviennent des montagnes de problème
quand on passe quarante quatre jours à
s'observer matin et soir et soir et
matin mais l'amitié reste solide amitié
n'est pas n'est pas remise en cause mais
si vous voulez le fait de voir quelqu'un
fume et en laissant tomber ça semble
dans un cockpit systématiquement pendant
44 jours à la fin ça vous semble étrange
qu'est ce que vous voulez prouver
bernard de guy vous et vos amis en
faisant ce tour du monde qu'il est
possible avec des amis justement de
partir pendant un certain nombre de mois
vivre une aventure qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire par rapport à la vie en
société actuelle l'appât du gain peut
être non ça je pense que plus tôt c'est
chez petiot la voie inverse même mais
pourquoi pas parce qu'on va plutôt je
pense se retrouver tout seul plus
fauchés qu'au départ étant donné qu'on a
vraiment investi tout ce qu'on pouvait
investir chacun dans ce bateau et
qu'elle arrive et il va falloir qu'on
commence à travailler sac pour pour
faire vivre les autres on souhaite bon
vent pour la suite de cette course
autour du monde prochaines étapes à
partir du 25 octobre direction auckland
voilà oui bon vent et le temps est bien
la journée était belle de dans beaucoup
de régions mais dans le nord-est et
brouillard ont persisté longtemps il
faisait seulement vis degrés à nancy et
strasbourg 10 à dijon souvent beaucoup
plus chou ailleurs 25 à biarritz par
exemple demain à l'exception de
l'extrême nord-est où il y aura toujours
des brouillards et des nuages assez bas
le temps restera le plus souvent
ensoleillé il y aura toutefois un peu
plus de nuages que les jours précédents
dans l'ouest et le sud-ouest les
températures varieront peut donc belle
journée à vous jean claude narcy pour
les autres nouvelles de ce journal en
bref le délégué français à la conférence
de belgrade est intervenu aujourd'hui
pour déplorer le procès de quatre
intellectuels tchécoslovaque accusé de
subversion
les journalistes occidentaux n'ont pas
pu entrer dans les lieux se déroule le
procès pourtant parmi eux il y à un
journaliste jiri leader à ce propos lus
énergie qui regroupe l'ensemble des
syndicats de journalistes français
réclament une autorisation pour
rencontrer notre confrère et assister à
son procès des visas ont été refusés en
particulier un jour
alice de l'humanité et le quotidien
communiste protestent aujourd'hui contre
ce refus le maréchal tito et arrive à
lisbonne en voyage officiel il avait
quitté mont-de-marsan ce matin à bord de
son boeing personnel après les
réceptions parisienne le chef de l'état
yougoslave a effectué un séjour privé
dans les landes à eugénie les bains où
il a pu profiter des promenades et
surtout de la gastronomie de cette
merveilleuse région en savourant les
confits et autres foie gras une
initiative originale de notre confrères
d'outre-rhin d'yvette qui pour la
première fois consacre un supplément de
douze pages entièrement à la région de
champagne ardenne objectif de die welt
mieux faire connaître la france
industrielle à son premier partenaire
économique
la république fédérale d'allemagne échec
pour le professeur barnard l'homme à qui
ils avaient greffé un coeur de
chimpanzés n'a pu survivre que quatre
jours
fernand car y aurait été acquitté le
jeune homme de 26 ans avait tué sa mère
vous en souvenez sa mère qu'il adorait
pour abréger ses souffrances
elle était atteinte d'un cancer
incurable rap de la petite graziella
rendu à sa famille contre 10 millions de
francs un homme une femme ont été
arrêtés par la police suisse mais les
policiers restent discrets sur les deux
suspects en tous les cas aucun des
billets ayant servi à payer la rançon
n'est réapparu depuis ce matin les
fumeurs risquent de payer une amende de
40 à 80 francs s'il s'adonne alors vice
préféré dans un lieu public
en effet les décrets d'application de la
loi anti tabac sont entrés en vigueur
ces mesures qui dans l'esprit de madame
veil sont destinés à protéger les non
fumeurs et en particulier les enfants
risquent fort d'avoir pour le
contrevenant un certain goût amer le roi
des cascadeurs est mort casse-cou du
cinéma français des années 30
roland toutain est décédé à l'âge de 72
ans il fut le merveilleux rouletabille
des films de marcel l'herbier le mystère
de la chambre jaune et le parfum de la
dame en noir
marc chagall a été honoré ce matin au
louvre pour la première fois le plus
célèbre musée du monde a accueilli le
son vivant un peintre contemporain
valéry giscard d'estaing était venu en
personne pour inaugurer l'exposition du
pavillon de flore ou chagall présente
une soixantaine de ses peintures les
plus récentes
je rappelle que marc chagall à est âgé
de 90 ans
voilà comme promis nous allons
maintenant votre vie bernard volker à
bonn il n'y a pas eu beaucoup d'éléments
nouveaux depuis tout à l'heure je pense
mais nous allons voir là bas comment et
le climat après le développement c'est
tragique de la situation aujourd'hui la
mort du commandant de bord de l'appareil
de la lufthansa a durci l'attitude du
gouvernement de bonn qui a pour la
première fois dit clairement cet après
midi qu'il n'envisageait pas de céder
aux exigences des terroristes est de
libérer la bande à baader
la fermeté du gouvernement allemand
n'est pas approuvée à 100% par l'opinion
publique allemande et le chancelier
schmidt se demande ce soir quelle sera
la réaction de l'opinion publique si par
exemple les terroristes décide
d'exécuter un à un les passagers de
l'avion de la lufthansa à une heure
d'intervalle
il semble que dans ce cas le
gouvernement allemand demanderait à
l'armée somalienne d'intervenir
le représentant personnel du chancelier
monsieur vichnievsky aidé à mogadishu il
négocie avec le gouvernement somalien
qui ne paraît pas pour le moment être
très désireux de se mêler de cette
affaire et de plus les soldats somaliens
ne sont pas non plus entraînés à ce
genre d'action le chantier les chiites a
expliqué aujourd'hui par téléphone au
président somalien siad barré pourquoi
il refuse relâchés la bande à baader
c'est ce que l'on a appris cet après
midi au cours de la conférence de presse
du porte-parole du gouvernement
schmidt ya eu un contact téléphonique
partout qu'une heure avec le président
de son mari monsieur paré est là et
essayer de faire clair à monsieur le
président de quoi il s'agit avec les
terroristes
combien de meurtres ils sont commis
combien ne meurent ils sont essayés
c'était pour faire clair ce qui signifie
les terroristes pour l'allemagne
fédérale
il a eu des contacts avec les
gouvernements
la france la grande bretagne et les
etats unis aussi l'hypothèse d'une
intervention militaire de l'armée
allemande contre les pirates qui
détiennent l'avion de la lufthansa est
elle envisagée non non le goff lra
personne n'y a pensé je crois qu à moi
que contrairement à ce que dit le porte
parole
l'idée d'une intervention militaire est
toujours envisagé la sphère traumatise
d'autant plus les allemands qu'ils sont
maintenant convaincus qu'ils n'en ont
pas fini avec le terrorisme et la
famille du président du patronat
allemand mais cela hier dont on est sans
nouvelles depuis l'expiration de
l'ultimatum a tenté mais sans doute sans
succès de prendre elle même directement
contact avec les ravisseurs de monsieur
la fière aujourd'hui elle veut
maintenant agir pour son propre compte
puisque maintenant c'est clair le
gouvernement ne fera rien elle proposera
aux ravisseurs une très forte somme
d'argent plusieurs milliards c'est
également tout ce que le gouvernement
allemand peut proposer en ce moment à
mogadishu aux terroristes qui détiennent
l'avion on s'achemine donc
inéluctablement
c'est ce que l'on pense ici vers une
solution de force oui en tout cas
attendons et ça change vous rappelle que
le dernier ultimatum expire cette nuit à
1h30 heure française et puis je vous
rappelle aussi d'informations je vous
donnais au début de ce journal le pape
paul 6 s'est offert lui même comme
otages à la place des otages du boeing
kid allemande lufthansa qui se trouvait
à mogadiscio
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut vers 23h35
merci